because it's like jacked with adrenaline
your brain it just starts going faster
you know and all of a sudden you can
process all these things you know and
it's kind of this crazy like slow-mo
experience you know where you're just
slowly falling with the water lots of
people like kayaking and some even enjoy
running whitewater but then there's
Raphael Ortez he doesn't just seek out
class five Rapids
he hits straight for what most avoid at
all costs massively steep waterfalls the
tallest one he's run is a hundred and
eighty nine feet tall
that's like paddling off the 20th floor
of a building the Leaning Tower of Pisa
or the Cinderella castle at the Magic
Kingdom I see a waterfall and I see a
line I see like opportunity and you
challenge you know instead of just this
beautiful phenomenon of nature and it's
kind of a blessing but also a curse at
the same time you know cuz if it speaks
to you it's hard not to want to do it
always people think I'm crazy and I must
be crazy because everybody says so we're
test takes his death-defying stunts to
truly absurd levels and he does it just
for fun I watched the video when I was a
kid if a guy going over a waterfall on
fire and I always wanted to try it I
feel like that's one of my weaknesses I
always look at crazy things and in my
head I think they're gonna be easy I'm
always very optimistic like that you
know when it actually comes down to
doing it a project like that I was like
you know we'll just hire some
professionals and you know put a bunch
of gasoline on me and you know wear the
right safety and just run you know go
over a waterfall in my kayak on fire
even once traded his kayak in for a
novelty inflatable toy shaped like a
lobster just for the pictures in there
laughs I drove up to the 70 foot tall
waterfall stood over the lip you know
just got ready jumped into the water
spinning a hundred and eighty degrees in
the air landed control myself look down
big fist pump at built live and once
Ortez and his friends set up a whole
night shoot with giant LED lights and a
Jenner
just because he thought it would look
cool we basically stayed in the forest
through the night till 4:00 or 5:00 in
the morning freezing and running this
waterfall at night with little headlamps
we're just doing it because it was cool
making it happen Ortez his love of river
started young
he was rafting around 8 years old and
got a kayak for his birthday when he was
14 so he said Eastern Mexico the state
of it I could who's where I learned how
to kayak just happens to be one of the
best places in the planet for a
waterfall descending in kayaks you know
few years into my paddling career I
realized that my backyard was perfect
for waterfalls so I started getting into
running waterfalls
you know without really any instruction
I just started you know watching videos
online ordering you know VHS tapes and
seeing how these guys were you know
going over these waterfalls in their
kayaks and I just started trying that in
my backyard and wasn't pretty at the
start I still remember the experience
running my very first tall waterfall it
was this 40-foot drop on the hiko River
in Veracruz and it came out at the
bottom it was a big hit I came out
seeing stars I actually broke my paddle
look back at the waterfall and I was
like this is crazy
yeah the next thing I knew I was you
know going all in on this new sport that
I quickly got addicted to you know the
first time you do it
everything happened super quick but once
you start doing this over and over again
and you started really kind of feeling
it you know you start getting better at
it
things just start happening a little bit
slower
Huerta's has spent the last two decades
pushing the limits on this sport one
that offers very little room for error
what does a seen his fair share of
injuries and he's watched his friends
come close to death back in 2013 he was
kayaking with his friend Jared Serra so
leaves in Mexico Sarah so Leah's went
over before Ortez but got swept under
the falls
I was behind him I went over the
waterfall when I came out I didn't see
anyone as I looked down the river a
little further downstream I saw one of
my friends pulling my my friend's body
out of the water and he was completely
just floppy you know he was pretty
lifeless he was purple very colorless he
was not breathing I think we must have
worked on him for a full three minutes
of these exhausting compressions just
taking turns mouth-to-mouth shouting you
know and it was just this crazy blur and
eventually three minutes in he goes and
takes a breath as kayakers because we're
always in these remote places we have to
learn how to rescue each other you know
as you know a kayaker that dedicates to
pushing the limits and facing risk on a
daily basis you know you always kind of
question when are you gonna finally
confront death surviving these drops
requires a lot of experience intuition
and a locked-in technique because in the
end you got to land safely and that
means going over the lip with the right
speed and the right form it all kind of
comes down to two things one of them is
speed more speed translates into more
angle so more of a flats landing less be
translated into more of a vertical
entrance and then the other thing number
two is the stroke that you take at the
lip you know as you're going over you
have to be taking one or two paddle
strokes to correct your angle if it's a
large waterfall anything above 40 feets
you want to make sure that you're as
vertical as possible instead of just
free-falling over the edge Ortez uses
the speed of the water and his paddle
strokes to position himself to land
safely for smaller waterfalls he wants
to land on top of the water let's say if
under 40 feet for a waterfall you
actually want to be coming in ideally at
like a 45 degree angle
right of the lip I'm gonna look down
lock my landing but then I want to take
a pretty long steady stroke that kind of
lifts the bow of my kayak so that way I
can you know kind of lock in that
45-degree angle if you do it right
you're able to just kind of skim the
surface and then resurface pretty
quickly but for water falls taller than
45 feet he wants to go over vertically
so when he dies into the water at the
bottom he slices into it with as little
impact as possible getting that vertical
position means going over the edge with
less speed so that the front of the boat
Falls and points down if it's a taller
waterfall once I'm in the current I'm
actually even like back paddling
sometimes a little bit you know I'm kind
of way more conservative with my speed
because that along with a stroke that I
take of the lip is gonna define the
angle if it's a large waterfall anything
above 40 feets you want to make sure
that you're as vertical as possible so
as your free-falling
you're not just closing your eyes and
shouting in the end it all comes down to
the impact so whenever you enter the
water down at the bottom of the
waterfall you basically want to be as
aerodynamic as possible or aqua dynamic
and you just want to kind of become as
slim as you can you want to make sure
that you either throw your paddle and
hug your boat tightly or like I usually
tuck my pal to this side and then I use
my right arm to protect myself and brace
for impact if you forget about this
often you end up taking a paddle in the
face and can result in stitches like
have probably had more than five times
in my paddling career
then there's finding it a good waterfall
or teza search has taken him around the
world think about waterfall descending
is that every waterfall is completely
different and in order to find that
dream waterfall that you've pictured you
have to find it you know we do a lot of
Google Earth you know satellite imaging
looking at these rivers that have the
right amount of steepness try to find
information about the volume of water
and then if everything lines up you go
explore the river and you might get
lucky and finds the next huge waterfall
and when he finds a good river he
studies it first before you go into a
waterfall you want to look at it from
every angle you want to do your due
diligence and study it correctly to make
sure it's a good decision to start with
every River is different there's a
thousand different factors every country
every area is different it has a
different kind of rock so you're either
talking about basalt you know a rock
that's like fairly crumbly but creates
these really nice waterfalls or you're
talking about limestone you know this
waterfall that's a lot more solid the
other big ingredient into the formula is
steepness you know cuz you're looking
for a certain kind of gradient but it
really relates to the amount of water so
you're either talking about a river that
it's a small trickle of water or you're
talking about you know a large river
that's a big beast you know that comes
with a lot of other factors and a lot of
risks and before I get into my kayak I'm
looking at the current and I'm kind of
visualizing myself step number one I'm
scouting the waterfall I'm studying it
and I know if it's a waterfall but I
have to for sure going vertical
this isn't just a physical sport coupled
with good gear for tez he needs to trust
his intuition a lot of it comes down to
your own experience you know and your
own trial and error you own
understanding even your own mindset you
know because a lot of it is mental you
know there's definitely a physical
aspect to it but a lot of it is a really
big mental game you know cuz you're
dealing with a lot of stress a lot of
fear all this adrenaline and then just
kind of finding your own Zen you know
finding your own sweet spot you know or
you can kind of find that calm it's kind
of cool you know I think it's it's
almost like a superpower adrenaline the
end the end I believe it's you know the
most powerful superpower that we could
have or tez has been kayaking
professionally for over ten years
for companies like redbull and Jackson
kayaks but it's not always about the
competition for him as he's getting
older or Tess's focus is shifting a
little I've definitely been moving you
know from the really tall waterfalls to
other kinds of more creative projects
I've also moved a lot recently towards
environmental projects couple years ago
I started doing River cleanups I feel
like as kayakers we have the opportunity
and for being on these beautiful rivers
and often we just find garbage you know
and find how human beings are slowly
destroying these beautiful natural
environments and the other aspect that
I've also try to try to help push is
avoiding and taking down dams in the
world because they will they basically
destroy the environment starting a
family also changed his perspective you
know now that I have a family and just
had a daughter a year ago and you know
my life is definitely getting a little
more complicated than it was even four
years ago because all of a sudden you
know from making decisions a hundred
percent for myself and you know decide
if deciding if I'm willing to put my
life in the line thinking about myself
now I think about my daughter first you
know and if if anything was to happen to
myself
you know it's it's more about her not
having a dad so it's definitely changed
you know me even just looking at danger
even just standing in front of a
waterfall and looking at risk with
almost different eyes but nothing will
stop them from kayaking even though it
seems absurd to find peace while going
over a waterfall
that's exactly why Ortez loves it once
you get inside your kayak and you close
it up you peel out into the currents
it's kind of cool because there's no way
back you know it kind of fear kind of
disappears you know because you're so
focused on the task and then you just
kind of start flowing with the river you
kind of you just kind of zone in you
know into this one task there's nothing
else in the world problems disappear
that's it like the moment